اتحدث اليوم الى مغيس جوغدو مونتاني
الدبلوماسي الفرنسي الذي وصفته صحيفه
لومونت بانه احد اهم مسؤوليه دبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه خلال السنوات الثلاثين الاخيره
عرف وفوض رؤساء الغرب والشرق حيث عمل
رئيسا لمستشاري الرئيس جاك شيراك ومديرا
لمكتب رئيس الحكومه السابق اعلان وسفيرا
لفرنسا في المانيا وبريطانيا والصين
واليابان في عهدين كلاسركوزى
وهولاند وتولى منصب الامين العام للخارجيه
الفرنسيه في عهد ايمانويل ماكرون الاول
قبل تقاعده اخيرا انا منتهى الرمحي احييكم
من العربيه اينما كنتم
والود
الاخر
من جديد اهلا بكم كتب جديده تهتم بالاحداث
السياسيه
والمتغيرات التي تهز العالم من ابرزها
كتاب الفه ضيفنا اليوم وصدر اول العام
بعنوان الاخرون لا يفكرون مثلنا هو كتاب
مذكراتاني الدبلوماسي الفرنسي الذي كان
اخر منصب يشغله هو الامين العام للخارجيه
الفرنسيه في عهد دائماويل ماكرون الاول
بعد ان عمل مع خمسه رؤساء وخمسه عشر وزير
خارجيه في كتابه استعرض لقاءاته مع بشار
الاسد لاجراء اصلاحات تتكيف مع متطلبات
الشعب السوري ويروي كيف انه بعد لقائه
ببشار الاسد مر الى بيروت للقاء رئيس
الوزراء اللبناني الراحل رفيق الحريري
ويعتقد الدبلوماسي رفيع المستوى ان هناك
رابطا بين تدخل روسيا في سوريا وعملياتها
في اوكرانيا حيث ان فلاديمير بوتين حصل
على دفعه قويه لديناميه الدبلوماسيه
الروسيه على جميع الصعد من دون رد فعل
الغرب كما اعتبر ان عدم التزام واشنطن
بالخط الاحمر الشهير الذي هدد به الرئيس
الامريكي حينها باراك اوباما بشار الاسد
اذا استخدم سلاح الكيماوي كان خطا كبيرا
ومن الاخطاء الاخرى القاتله حسب ضيفنا ان
الامريكيين لم يروا او لم يريدوا النظر
الى ان هناك منذ زمن طويل نقصا في الامن
في وسط اوروبا الذي يحيط اوكرانيا فلم
يفعلوا شيئا ولم يجلسوا الى طاوله مفاوضات
لمناقشه قضايا الامن وضبط السلاح حول
اوكرانيا كما استعرض العلاقات مع ايران
واعتبر انه لا يمكن التفاهم مع نظامها
فالامريكيون والاسرائيليون يقولون ان اير
ان وصلت الى الحد الاقصى ولكن السؤال هو
ان الروس قد وضعوا انفسهم في تقارب مع
ايران وهذا يمثل نوعا من خط الجبهه الذي
يضم روسيا ايران وباكستان والهند كما
افغانستان اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بضيفنا في
حلقه هذا الاسبوع من البعد الاخر
الدبلوماسي الكبير سعاده مغيث جوردو
مونتاني اهلا بك معنا
شكرا جزيلا
دعني ابدا معك
بكونك عملت مع خمسه رؤساء من ضمن ابرز
قاده العالم وعملت كذلك مع خمسه عشر وزيرا
للخارجيه كما انك تعد احد ابرز وجود
دبلوماسيه الاوروبيه في العقود الثلاثه
الاخيره على حد ما وصفتك به صحيفه
اللوموند الان وانت تعيش التقاعد كيف ترى
العالم هل يشبه ما توقعته عن مغادرتك
الدبلوماسيه
الكثير من الامور حدثت بعد مغادره
الدبلوماسيه عندما دخلت الى عالم
الدبلوماسيه في عام
1978 كان انذاك عهد اريجان الذي تحبه كذلك
ماركه
وصول الى ايران كان لم يتعلق بدانشو بينك
في الصين الذي كان لديه برنامج اصلاحاته
بعد اربعين عاما نرى اننا وصلنا الى نهايه
دائره العالم يعيد تنظيمه نفسه واعتقد
اننا اليوم في مرحله هي النفس ليس نفسها
بدات في الحرب البارده عرفت نهايه
الشيوعيه كان هناك الكثير من المراحل مثل
الربيع العربي والازمه الماليه فالعالم
يشكل نفسه من جديد
نزوع العالم نحو هذا الوضع من التوترات هل
بسبب افتقاده الى قاده مثل جاك شيراك الذي
اشد به ايما اشاد في كتاب مذكراتك
اعتقد ان سمت الكثير من العناصر عنصر
الرجال هو احد العناصر ولكن كما قلت
العالم تغير بشكل كبير نعيش في عالم بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اسس على قواعد
دوليه مع وجود الامم المتحده التي انضمت
اليها غالبيه الدول لكن الجهات الفاعله
تغيرت وهناك ايضا ما اسميها تحول
الاجيال وجيل اليوم ليرى العالم من منظور
مختلف اما كان عليه لما يوجد اليوم بلدان
لم تكن موجوده على الساحه في السنوات
الستين او السبعين الماضيه هناك دول حازت
استقلالها وهذه مساله مهمه هناك بلدان
ناشعه افكر في بلدان الكبرى مثل الصين
والهند وهناك ايضا عوده لتركيا
وهناك دول في الشرق الاوسط المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الامارات العربيه
المتحده في افريقيا نيجيريا هذه دول
الكبرى تريد ان تجد موتها قدم لها وهي
مساله مهمه فالعالم تغير بشكل جذري ثم
اشرت الى القائد جاك شيراك جاك شيراك كان
له ميزه الاستمراريه السياسيه فهو كان
رئيس وزاره مرتين وخلال 20 عاما كان عمده
باريس وعام 95 انتخب رئيس الجمهوريه وعيد
انتخابه عام 2002 وكان لديه
معارف كقائد الرئيس شراء كان لديه هذه
العلاقات التي سمحت له بان يفهم الاوضاع
وان يدخل في تفكير غالبيه شركاء على قدمي
المساواه وكان يركز او يهتم كثير بارائهم
اذكر بان رئيس شراكه ارسلني مرارا للالتقى
بالملك عبد الله في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
للاسترشاد برايه بشان قضايا بعينها واعتقد
ان هذا بالنسبه لتوازن في العالم
والاستقرار كان عاملا بالغه الاهميه وهذا
يذكرنا في الحقيقه برئيس اخر رئيس فرنسي
ربما يضعه البعض في العالم العربي في
الطرف الاخر المقابل للشراك نيكولاسر كوزي
عملت معه وانت ايضا هناك الكثير من
الاسئله تتعلق بدوره مثلا في قتل القذافي
وفيما حدث في ليبيا عام 2011
هل من معلومات لديك بشان هذا الموضوع
محقه الرئيس ركزي كان له نمط مختلف فهو
كان رئيس
شاب لم يعرف الحرب وكان يمثل الجيل الجديد
لسياسيين الفرنسي عملت مع الرئيس ركزي
كسفير في لندن في تلك الحقبه او وقعنا
اتفاقات دفاعيه كبرى مع البريطانيين وكان
هذا امرا جديدا تعلمين ان فرنسا والاتحاد
او المملكه المتحده كان عدوين
وبدات في بدايه القلعه 20 علاقه تفاهم
واستطعنا التعاون في الحربين
وبفضل رئيس سركوزي انتقلنا الى مرحله
اضافيه كنت سفيرا للرئيس سركوزي ايضا في
المانيا خلال الازمه الماليه واعتقد انه
بالنسبه لانقاذ منطقه اليورو في وقت كانت
اليونان مهدده جدا لعب دورا كبيرا واشرت
بطبيعه الحال الجانب اشرت الى جانب اخر
يتعلق بسياسه الرئيس سركوزي
وهو ما يسمى
بالربيع العربي هذه الاحداث التي نظر
اليها من قبل البلدان الغربيه كانها مرحله
انفتاح وتغيير لكن الامور غالبا انتهت
بطرق
عنيفه وفي ليبيا الوضع كان عنيف جدا لانه
كانت هناك حرب اهليه وجاء تدخل
العسكريين في ليبيا
بمشاركه 53 دوله وقرار للامم المتحده
وجامع الدول العربيه ولكن هذه العمليه لم
تكن مخطط لها بطريقه جيده وتنفيذها لم يكن
جيدا من حيث النتائج وصحيح انه في النهايه
قالت اليه الامور الى مالت اليه الت الى
وضع ماساوي وتداعيات هذه العمليه غير
المخطط لها بطريقه جيده هذا امر يجب ان
نقر به اليوم فهذا بلد لا يمكن او ليس
هناك حكومه تحكمه
انتشار اسئله اذا
سجل الرؤساء واحاول في كتاب ان اكون
موضوعيا هناك طبعا بعض الامور الايجابيه
والسلبيه ولكن اعتقد ان مرحله التدخلات
العسكريه الكبرى في خارج في الخارج هي
مرحله قد
مضت وكما قلت اليوم هناك الكثير من
الفاعلين ويجب بناء عالم يعيد تنظيم نفسه
وفقا
لاقطاب يمكن ان تتفاهم فيما بينها وكذلك
تحدد قواعد اللعبه هذه المرحله التي نتحدث
عنها اظهرت قواعد اللعبه انها لا تشرك ما
يجب سنذهب الى فاصل قصير ونعود بعده
لمتابعه حوارنا مع الدبلوماسي الكبير
ارحب بسعاده موريس جوردو مونتاني مره اخرى
اهلا بك معنا سعاده السيد تحدثت قبل قليل
عن شجاعه الرئيس شيراك في سياساته
الخارجيه كما تحدثت في مذكراتك ايضا منها
قرار مثلا استخدام الفيتو بوجه الامريكيين
في حربهم على العراق وغضب بش انذاك لو
تذكرنا بهذه الحادثه لو سمحت
[موسيقى]
هذه العمليه ستكون اولا غير قانونيه غير
شرعيه ولن تحصل على دعم من المجتمع الدولي
والنتيجه نتيجه هذه العمليه ستكون زعزعه
استقرار المنطقه برمتها والتي هي بالاساس
هشه وكذلك توازنات الموجوده لن تكون
موجوده في المستقبل بعد العملي وبالتالي
يبدو سيكون هناك فوضى عارمه وبتاكيد موجه
ارهاب ستكون خطيره للغايه وقد اضاف والغرب
سيفقد شرفه ولا يمكن لنا ان نؤيدكم في هذه
العمليه طبعا الرئيس بشرى انزعج كثير من
هذا الموقف وكان لدينا شعور انذاك وتاكد
ذلك عندما ارسلني الرئيس شيراقلى واشنطن
في بدايه عام 2003 قبل الحرب باسابيع
ادركنا ان الهدف كان تغيير النظام في
العراق واسلحه قمر شامل كان ذريعه فقط
لانها جاءت في نهايه اولويات الامريكيين
ببساطه لانه لم يكن هناك اسلحه دمار شامل
في العراق وبالتالي كان هذا وضع بالغ
الصعوبه
وما حدث في العراق الحقيقي او تبعاته ما
زال العراق يعاني منها حتى الان الموقف
كان مختلف فيما يتعلق بلبنان لاحقا تم
التقارب بين بوش واشتراك حول لبنان ودور
الرئيس الراحل رفيق الحريري كيف بدا هذا
التقارب
لماذا حول رفيق الحريري تحديدا
بالنسبه لرئيس الشيراك لبنان كان ما يمثل
المختبر فيما يتعلق بالتطور في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط اي تعايش
مجموعات اجتماعيه ودينيه مختلفه لو نجحت
التجربه في لبنان فهذا يعني ان هذا يمكن
ان ينجح في اماكن اخرى ايضا اذا في هذا
الوضع كان هناك احتلال لبنان من قبل
القوات السوريه وبالتالي رئيس شراك بحث عن
دعم الولايات المتحده في وقت كنا في كانت
علاقاتنا سيئه مع واشنطن بسبب حرب العراق
كما اشرت اليه قبل قليل اذا كنا نحتاج
لموقف مجتمع دولي موحد اذاعه مشروع مشترك
كنا نريد علاقه نريد قرار من مجلس الامن
لمطالبه من انسحاب القوات السوريه من
لبنان لمنحي لبنان متنفس لم التي التنميه
والاستقرار وتجنب التدخل الاجنبي
تعلمين كيف
حدث ذلك فتم اغتيال رفيق الحريري وبعد ذلك
لم تنسحب الا بعد عام من ذلك وهذه هي كانت
النتيجه السياسه التي انتهجت في ذلك الوقت
طيب على ذكر رفيق الحريري في كتابك الذي
لخصت في مسيرتك الدبلوماسيه نفهم انك تتهم
النظام السوري باغتيال رفيق الحريري بناء
على ماذا جاء هذا الاستنتاج
لا استطيع ان اقول انني اتهم نظام السوري
بذلك ففي ذلك الوقت كما تعلمين
به لجنه التحق تحقيق على الارض وتم طبعا
استجواب شهود وتم توقيف بعض الاشخاص كل
ذلك جرى في سياق بالغ صعوبه
والتعقيد في لبنان وفي المنطقه ايضا كان
هناك عدد من الوقائع جعلتنا نتساءل ولكن
لم يعد لنا ولا يمكن ان نقول له شخصيا
لا يمكن نقول ان سوريا هي المسؤوله كان
هناك عوامل تجعلنا نعتقد بان رفيق الحريري
كان يزعج وان اختفائه كان يخدم مصالح
البعض لا استطيع ان اضيف اكثر من ذلك بس
الى اي حد يمكن ان نقول بانه فرنسا
فشلت في قضيه المحكمه الدوليه تجاه رفيق
الحريري
من فشل ليست فرنسا وانما المجتمع الدولي
برمته فقد اشرت الى التعقيدات على الارض
لاجراء تحقيق وكذلك الاعتراضات التي تجلت
في اماكن متعدده لعرقله التحقيق وكذلك
الوقت الذي احتجته لجنه تحقيق لاستجواب
بعض الاشخاص اذا لم نتوصل
لتحديد مسؤوليات المسؤوليات في هذا هذا
الاغتيال هذا فشل هل هو فشل فرنسا ام
لبنان اعتقد انه فشل جماعي للاسف والوضع
اليوم يظل بالغ التوتر والصعوبه التقيت
رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد وركزت معه
حول الاصلاحات
لو تحدثنا عن ذلك وكيف اخطا بتقدير انك
مبعوث امريكي وليس من فرنسا
استقبلني الرئيس بشار الاسد بطلب من
الرئيس شيراك وكان ذلك بعد الحرب على
العراق مباشره
والرئيس شراك بالتشاور مع المستشار
الالماني جيرارد شرودر ورئيس الروسي
راى بانه بعد الحرب في العراق كان من
المهم ان نشير الى شريك مثل سوريا بان
الامور قد حركت وبالتالي كان ينبغي ان
تقوم سوريا بدور اكثر نشاط في الحياه
الدوليه شراك لذلك قبل الحرف العراق حيث
ان شراك كان مقربا من حافظ الاسد والد
بشار الاسد وقد راى بان اعاده دمج سوريا
على الساحه الدوليه سيكون عاملا ايجابيا
للمجتمع الدولي وكذلك
لسوريا نفسها وقد حاول ج
الاسد يستقبله عدد من الشركاء الاوروبيون
وكنا في وضع بعد الحرب ارسلني رئيس شراكي
الى هناك واستقبلت استقبلت لساعات طويله
ام مع من قبل الرئيس الشراك الذي رحب به
كثيرا قلت له من المهم ان تبادر نحن لا
نقول لكم ما هي هذه المبادره لانكم
بلد ذو سياده وانت الرئيس السوري القرار
يعود لك ولكن اللي تعلم اذا قمت بذلك
سندعم اي مباراه لا يمكن ان تدمجكم اكثر
في المجتمع الدولي
عكس ما قيل فانني لم اقترح عليه ان يعيد
الجولان او زياره اسرائيل لان هذه مباراه
كانت
مستحيله وبدون جدوى وما كان علينا ان نقول
له ما عليه ان يبدو له ولكن كنا نريد منه
اشاره بانه يقوم بدور نشد ولكن قال للرئيس
بشار هل الولايات المتحده هي التي ارسلتك
اذا كان من جانبه ربما توقع لزياره من
الامريكيين لم تتجسد وانتهت المحادثه على
هذا الاساس واستطيع ان اقول ان الرئيس
شيراك اسفه كثيرا لعدم وجود اي رد على
المقترح الفرنسي والالماني والروسي في ذلك
الوقت هل تتصور بانه ترك الغربي يتدخل في
سوريا بالشكل الذي تدخل فيه وبقاء روسيا
فيها مع قواعد بحريه شجعوا على غزو
اوكرانيا شجع بوتين على غزو اوكرانيا
يمكن ان نقول عندما ننظر الى الوضع باعين
اليوم
لم نكن ربما متبصرين جيدا بشان اتواجد
الروسي في سوريا عندما وقعت الحرب الاهليه
في سوريا
سالنا التقدير فيما يتعلق بالوجود الروسي
او البعض في ذلك الوقت لم يريدوا ان
ينظروا الى روسيا شاليك في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط روسيا بوتين عادت بقوه الى هذه
المنطقه سواء كان في مصر او في سوريا
وبناء عليه وبطريقه ما عدم النظر الى
الواقع سامحني لبوتين بالتصرف وفي هذا
الوقت بطبيعه الحال بهذا ربما من
الحسابات التي قام بها الرئيس بوتين عندما
غزا اوكرانيا بان ردود فعل الغرب لن تكون
مؤثره وهذا الى حد ما ربما شجعه على
الذهاب في هذا الاتجاه لكنه ليس بسبب
الرئيسي لكن كان لينا ايضا موقف اخر تحميل
لانتقاد للموقف الامريكي وفي تجاهل هواجس
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قد تحدث عنه
بعد قليل لكن دعنا نذهب الى ايران هل
تعتقد انه من الممكن التفاهم حاليا مع هذا
النظام الايراني
جدا بسبب المظاهرات المستمره منذ شهور
والتي يقودها جيل جديد واعتقد ان هنا ايضا
هناك انتقال للاجيال وهو امر يجب اخذه في
الحسبان بشكل عام رغبه فرنسا دائما وابدا
كانت القول ان ايران موجوده هي موجوده في
المنطقه ويجب ان يكون لديها مكان او مكان
يمكن ان يتم التشاور بشانه مع الدول
المجاوره نحن كنا مهتمين بان ايران عبر
ربما وسطات او او
مثل حزب الله والحوثيين يحاولوا اتموقع في
مناطق اخرى لحمايه نفسه وكذلك زعزعه بلدان
الاقليم هذا امر غير مقبول وعملنا
بان يندمج الايرانيون في المجتمع الدولي
واكد على ذلك ولكن ربما يحتاجون لمكانهم
المناسب مع مراعاه بان الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه تريد ان تتمدد وهذا ايضا عنصر
يجب اخذه في موازين القوه التي نريدها
ولكن الفكره هي ان يتم تجنب وكان هذا هو
هدف
الاتفاق النووي الذي للاسف انسحب منه
الامريكيون اذا الهدف هو منح ايران
مكانه او مكانتها
وان تبقى ايران عند مستوى معين في المجال
النووي ان تستفيد من الاستثمارات ثم تندمج
في المجتمع الدولي الرئيس ترامبول
الامريكي انتقدوا موقف معاكس وبالتالي لا
يمكن اصلاح كسر وبالتالي ايران موجوده
اليوم وهي طبعا
داخلي لا نعلم
الامور لكن الاكيد هو ان ايران من خلال
بعض التصرفات تعرض للخطر الاستقرار في عدد
من البلدان في المنطقه هذه المنطقه التي
هي بحاجه للاستقرار وما يهم هو ان تحل هذه
المنطقه مشكلاتها بنفسها مع دعم بطلب من
هذه البلدان بدعم من البلدان الاجنبيه
فرنسا
والولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
مستعدون لدعم هذه المنطقه لتحقيق
الاستقرار لان ذلك في مصلحه الجميع
فالاستقرار مهم لتنميه الشعوب وازدهارها
هذا هو الوضع هو غير مستقر وقد يظل كذلك
لفتره من الزمن الى هنا تنتهي حلقه اليوم
من البعد الاخر يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك
ويوتيوب كما يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا
على العربيه بودكاست ومشاهدتها على منصه
شاهد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]